well you know companies like tick tock
and this kind of uh deal is is kind of a
dream come true for
uh for the chinese community's party
they probably
you know believe that we're pretty uh
incredibly stupid to let this kind of
things happen
grand forks airflow space has the global
hawk drone program which is one of the
most innovative
drone technology in the world so that's
a pretty big concern
for china to be able to be
so close to this it's very possible that
china is privatizing locations close to
military bases it wouldn't be surprising
we know that
they are very good at collecting data in
front of our noses and quite honestly
the fact that we let them buy 200 000
acres of property in the united states
is uh it's mind-boggling you wonder
sometimes
why congress is sleeping at the wheel
well the chinese community party is very
good at spying they can do it in a very
covert way where most people wouldn't
have no clue that it's happening in
front of the eyes so
i'm sure that the employees the american
employees of the company believe
that this would never happen but
i wouldn't be
so
trustful
i can tell you that what they can do is
is pretty
uh scary and in a way that most people
would not know what's going on and and
they have patience you know they they
can literally invest in this land for 10
15 20 years in the hope that they're
going to get access to the next
generations of weapons so it might not
be a short-term plan and maybe nothing
is going to happen on the short term
but the fact is long term it's probably
not a good idea to let china being so
close to an air force base but they have
they have so many ways between
cyber offense and the media and now you
know companies like tick tock of course
uh being able to collect data from a
massive number of citizens and even
controlling what they get to see or
think about or search uh so they are
really imposition of a of a weapon of uh
misinformation potentially and uh um
mass control of uh of people's mind and
that's uh that's a strategic advantage
over a variety nation well if 50 of
congress was not still struggling to
turn on the smartphone and understand
the importance of data and machine
learning and ai you would probably see a
much broader engagement when it comes to
data privacy
and making sure that china is not able
to steal
the american citizens data uh yet you
see pretty much no actions it's almost
like we are willingly letting china get
a massive foothold in the united states
of course we're a free market but we
shouldn't be also
imbeciles
imbeciles
unfortunately we had the wrong leaders
and we still do with the chairman of the
joint staff still
diminishing
the damages created by china and calling
china neoprene adversary and and calling
the hypersonic launches an almost uh
sputic moment when it is a sputnik
moment and so always diminishing uh the
the problem uh which really uh is kind
of to cover at the end of the day the
incompetence and complacency uh after
having taken no action for for many
years and letting china slowly but truly
take over some of the key
weapon capability that will let us win
the next battles
[Music]